[Music]
Abby thank you so much for being here
with me so I want to start by saying
what problem were you trying to solve
when you started missfit market so we
were actually trying to solve two okay
um and they're they're tied although
I'll talk about them differently the
first one is just the massive amount of
food waste that exists in the US and and
the idea for Misfits came from me going
to a farm and seeing that for every
Apple that was on a tree there would be
10 on the
that the farmer was saying I'm going to
throw out um and so there's a huge
amount of food waste and you'll see
stats like you know a third of the food
that's grown in the US goes to waste
before it actually makes it to the
consumer so that's one huge problem
we're trying to tackle and the other
problem is um at the same time there
there are so many folks that don't have
access to healthy affordable food in the
United States and you know I um I have
spent a lot of time in Philadelphia
that's why I started Misfits and even
within the city of Philadelphia um there
are you know census designated food
deserts uh Urban food deserts where you
know you can go buy cheese steak and
potato chips but you can't buy a fresh
Apple um and what was mindboggling to me
was the fact that while you have these
food deserts here an hour out you have a
farmer throwing away perfectly fine
apples and so our goal with Misfits was
to tackle those two problems at the same
time the the the sustainability problem
and the accessibility problem with food
interesting now what are you doing that
is totally different from competitors
like Fresh Direct or
instacart yeah so so I think there's
there's two fundamental things about our
model that are different the first is um
we're not buying the regular food that
you'd see at the grocery store um we're
buying you know we started our brand was
originally known for ugly produce uh
it's a produce that's like too small too
large it's you know squashed it's curved
in a crazy you know crazy shape um so so
that's how we started and over time
we've expanded our assortment and the
unifying theme has been sort of the ugly
groceries that traditional grocery
stores won't buy for reasons that you
and I kind of would think are somewhat
ridiculous because that's just how our
industry operates in grocery um and so
that's our primary focus is like the
ugly Misfit groceries of the world that
wouldn't make it to to to to store
shelves because you know they're too
small they're too large the packaging is
old or um you know another area we play
in a lot is things where you know the
the expiration date might be 120 days or
180 days that's not enough for a grocery
store to take advantage of but that is
for a direct consumer e-commerce
platform so that's one huge difference
of our model the second one is we work
directly with the farmers and producers
um there are a lot of kind of e-commerce
models out there in grocery where they
use third parties they use Distributors
um if we have an interesting little uh
an infographic that shows the life of an
apple um when you order it on Misfits
versus when you go and buy it from the
grocery store and you buy it from the
grocery store that Apple goes to 10
different places along the way it goes
to a co-packer then a distributor and
then a regional distribution center and
then the local distribution center and
then the store um and that's also the
case for a lot of the other traditional
e-commerce grocery platforms for us the
Apple goes from the farm to a Misfits
Warehouse to your doorstep um so I think
those are the two fundamental
differences it's it's how we source and
then our our much kind of tighter
smaller supply chain now I'm curious
about the consumer psychology behind all
of this because how do you change a
consumer's mind then who's used to
getting you know a bright red beautiful
Apple from stop and shop as opposed to
like going to misfit's Market how do you
get them to make that change yeah the
it's it's a great question because the
customer education side of this has been
hugely important for us um and and when
we first started I think there was some
hesitancy people are like well do I want
to buy the ugly Apple but it was
actually more it was less so coming from
a place of they were afraid of it being
ugly and they kind of it was more of a
lack of understanding it was like they
weren't actually sure what you know you
know ugly produce actually was um and we
we' tried kind of rebranding going from
ugly to Misfit you know there's company
that we we bought recently called
imperfect Foods so we use even use the
adjective imperfect but there's still
this learning Gap because most folks
don't understand what that means um and
what's interesting is when when our
customers get their first box their
immediate reaction when they open it up
is a lot of this stuff doesn't look
Misfit it actually looks fine um and so
we we spent a lot of time and energy
kind of educating the customer like hey
you might see kale that's got slight
discoloration on the edges or the tips
simply because it was exposed to a
little bit too much sunlight um two days
before Harvest or you know you might
have broccoli uh you know there's
something called purpling on Broccoli
heads where again due to temperature
changes the the green color on the top
of the broccoli would be a little bit
more purple shade than green shade does
not impact the quality at all does not
impact the nutrition or the taste just
aesthetic um so we've done a lot of sort
of customer education outward customer
education um to get that point across we
we partnered with folks that have voices
in the space so for example we did a
couple of years ago we did a huge
partnership with Bobby fle the celebrity
chef um because we were like you know
it's one thing if I'm sitting there on
TV or on on an ad telling folks like
don't worry your broccoli is fine it's
just a little purple but Bobby fle says
it um who is a name that folks recognize
and Trust around food maybe that helps
the customer education piece so so we
have seen over the past 5 years since
launch that um we we have kind of gone
over that hurdle for a lot of folks but
it's it's still kind of the biggest
challenge for us is like how do we get
people to understand that you know
Misfit does not equal bad um and how do
we make that really clear across all
these items now you mentioned your
imperfect Foods Acquisitions that's a
fellow under 30 you acquired the company
last year um and you recently told
another publication that you know that's
not your only acquisition talk to me
about your acquisition strategy and how
you're looking at that going forward
yeah um so you know imperfect was it was
not something I was planning on doing to
be honest honest um
we you know our m&a was something that
you know I thought about as hey maybe
like another five years on the line it's
something we'll consider and and do that
but um you know I think candidly like
the macro environment changed so
dramatically over the past couple of
years and there and we started seeing a
lot of companies that were evaluating
like should I go raise more Capital at
an onerous terms that are really
challenging with valuations that are
different than what they were 3 years
ago or should I consider strategic
Alternatives and so that's kind of how
the imperfect conversation came up was
they were considering a fundraise um but
as they were considering that they were
like we should probably also explore
doing something with with Misfits the
companies are more similar than they are
alike so um and then those conversations
very quickly became tactical like let's
actually do something my you know my
broad take on Direct consumer platforms
right now especially sort of like food
e-commerce grocery e-commerce is there
are a lot of companies that just don't
have the scale to be meaningfully
profitable
it's getting hard to get scale purely
from you know customer acquisition on
Facebook or Instagram whatever the
channels have been over the past few
years um and so there is a a a real we
see like a real consolidation happening
some of it is forc consolidation because
some companies have no other option um
and some of it is you know they you know
companies look at uh what used to be a
competitor and they say well now 1 plus
1 equals 3 if we can combine and reduce
costs and get synergies and all those
things so we we very much so and I very
much so believe that like consolidation
is going to be a big part of the future
of of the industry um we've proved our I
think we've proved our muscle with the
imperfect acquisition and so my hope is
that we can you know we'll do more of
these in the next uh next couple years
now speaking of that you had talked to
one of our fors reporters last year and
You' said that you know you couldn't
name a single Standalone profitable
online grocery company um but your
acquisition of imperfect would would
help Misfits achieve that did it um and
where are you at with profitability
today yeah we're um we're we're on on
track to get there um so so we outlined
such as when we did the imperfect
acquisition which was in um at the end
of October of 2022 we were like hey
here's the 18-month road map to get the
combined business profitability and
we're on track um I think our our our
kind of base case plan is in 2024 we get
to uh to to profitability so um on track
there and the imperfect acquisition was
a huge part of that um because the math
ended up being you know hey like
Standalone we have two subscale
companies um combining them and then
sort of you know consolidating
warehouses and combining Logistics
networks um Mak you know not having
duplicate assortments in the same
facilities uh that was a huge part of
achieving those synergies interesting
now you've had quite the fundraising
Journey too can you talk to me a little
bit about that and how you're looking at
taking on Capital going forward yeah um
you know I I think our goal is that we
are able to get to meaningful cashow
profitability with our current balance
sheet um so you know whether we get
there is still kind of like TBD but but
I think the goal is no additional
Capital coming into the business um and
you know we we've raised north of half a
billion dollars over the past few years
and we have an amazing A-list group of
investors that are incredibly supportive
so if we needed to raise more Capital we
could um but my goal is to get the
business to profitability and sort of
you know Standalone default alive
whatever the word is that people use
these days on the existing balance sheet
so I don't think we'll raise more
Capital um if we need it I think the you
know the opportunity exists but I don't
think we will um and then for us it
really just becomes a question of at
that point do we have the scale and do
we like the economic economics of the
business to then go go public at some
point what would it take for you to sell
your company and is that the goal ever
um it is not it is not our like first
our tier one goal um and part of that is
because I think what we're doing is very
different from um I believe what sort of
the the acquirers in the space are doing
um and you know my take is and what I
mean by that is traditionally the
acquires in this space have been brick
and mortar grocery retailers so like the
big behemoths that we're trying to
disrupt right and you know ultimately I
think my take on it is is if we try to
sell the business too early then the
disruptive force that we are um probably
stops that's that will no longer be the
case if we're kind of absorbed by a much
much larger old school Brick M grocery
retailer um and I think there's
incredible amount of Tam here to still
go after right if you look at online
grocery the the stats are kind of crazy
it's it's um it's almost a trillion
dollars of consumer spend in grocery and
only 11 or 12% of that's online right
now so even the $10 billion Market
you're still talking about you know sub
15% online penetration right and so my
hope is we can continue to kind of grow
this um as an independent company
whether it's a private company or public
company I think TBD and that will depend
on what the Market's like and you know
whether we like the IPO markets um but I
think our goal is to sort of continue to
build as a independent company for for
some period of time um we're always you
know we've gotten approached by
retailers and folks and asking and
poking around and we've just generally
said hey like now's not the time no you
talked about online grocery and I know
online the online grocery space exploded
during the pandemic y um how are you
looking at that now as there's kind of
this post pandemic slowdown yeah um I
think a couple things on it one
we the growth rates that people expected
and saw during 2020 and 2021 very
different from what we're seeing and
folks are seeing the industry in 2022
and 2023 um and I think that's just the
reality of it is like you know hey if
you have lockdowns and force everyone to
be at home they're going to order more
online and then once they start going
out and traveling more that will revert
a little bit more to the to the mean and
I think that reversion to the mean is
something that every food e-commerce
orer eCommerce company has seen over the
past couple of years um e-commerce in
general I think has seen that um but we
did this exercise internally where we
kind of plotted out um sort of uh from
survey data and from internal data what
the slope of like e-commerce adoption
for groceries look like pre-co and
postco and it's still accelerating um so
the the pace at which people want to
order groceries online and not go to
store that is still accelerating and we
still think there's you know that 120
billion out of the 1 trillion is still a
big opportunity but I think the growth
rates won't be the you know 100%
year-over year that that F on 20 20202
that makes sense and now I want to end
on what's next for you what's next next
for misfitz Market in
2024 yeah I think um you know the key
themes for us one we are um now that
we're officially done with our
integration of imperfect Foods we now
have like a single platform um that we
can Leverage The Grow moving forward and
so unified technology stack unified
operating system um unified Warehouse
Network Logistics Network and so that's
going to provide I think think a really
great foundation for us to grow um and
really for 2024 we are we are going to
be growing our assortment pretty
substantially uh with the goal of really
being a standalone online grocery store
um so there there's there's a lot of
categories that we don't even play in
today that we're planning on launching
in 2024 which I think are going to is
going to open up a ton of opportunity
for the consumer excellent well thank
you so much and good luck with that
thank you appreciate
it